mein name ist luca herzlich willkommen
wir heute meine lieben freunde zu einer
neuen folge ebay feld ich würde sagen
ich glaube heiß lang hat er verkauft
eine person auf kleinanzeigen ein
wunderschönes holzbett dann bekommt er
allerdings eine nachricht von einem
interessenten der schreibt hallo snow
dhabi zwar klimakammer gucke biete ja
also das würde mich auch interessieren
als erstes habe ich ja nie werkleiter
zeigen angebot gefunden von einer person
die definitiv lieber erst mal deutsch
lernen sollte und zwar verkauft die
person pflastersteine für selbstabholer
ja egal ich empfehle die wirklich hatte
das jetzt das anzeige bild vom nächsten
die befehle man denkt jetzt vielleicht
im ersten moment hey verkauft er
vielleicht das grillrost oder die
holzkohle darunter der verschenkt die
beiden bratwürstchen und er schreibt
auch noch unten hin sind über von gerade
wer hat hunger
suderwich ja also wenn einer von euch
noch höher
die wurden vor zwei jahren dar
eingestellt gehe hier verkauft jemand
seinen kaffee vollautomaten bei ebay und
eine person schreibt ihm was ist preis
danke und er antwortet einfach mit dem
wikipedia zu geil ich finde erklärt ihm
einfach was ein preise sei das ist ja
das alter bei diesem bild denkt man sich
vielleicht eher verkauft die
sonnenbrille die er gerade auf htm das
ist allerdings falsch denn er verkauft
eine relax massage für 15 euro und wohnt
in loxstedt und er schreibt in die
beschreibung ich bin mann 28 jahre alt
ich komme aus grease ich bin masuren ich
machen massage nur frauen relax massage
und antidepressive habe interesse
schreiben sms danke auch dir kann ich
wärmstens empfehlen
dann sprachen hier erkennt glaube ich
jeder dass das ein pinguin ist und man
denkt jetzt vielleicht hätte der verkauf
doch jetzt nicht irgendwie mit ihr bei
ebay kleinanzeigen vielleicht geht es
irgendwie um den boden darunter oder um
die gräser drum rum oder vielleicht um
zwei gutscheinen er verkauft hier eine
kleine katze
ja
so wie ihr gerade guckt habe ich auch
geguckt als ich das gefunden haben wir
verkauft eine hamburger einen mac
schicken classic das ist auch wieder
lustig weil der typ aus hamburg kommt
aber wegschicken verkauft gestern abend
im rahmen des angebots wegschicken
klassiker holt ein erreichte meiner
tochter nun liegt die andere verpackt im
kühlschrank wurde nicht abgebissen lage
ruf als jemand interesse hat zu schade
dass teil wegzuwerfen ich jetzt was
leider nicht abzuholen abnahmen tag in
hamm
warum gibst du als ort hamburg an wenn
du dann in die beschreibung haben
schreibst ihr verkauft jemand 16 zoll
räder und er bekommt die nachricht von
markt er da schreibt hallo kann ihnen
für die räder 30 euro zahlen mit vielen
grüßen mag
hallo 50 sind jedoch noch locker wert
ja also wenn ich auf jeden vertrauen
würde dann auf marken der markt mag auch
tomatenmark mich verpissen tja das ist
das nächste gb angebot und zwar seht ihr
schon kuchen zu verschenken und unten
städten wollen ich verschenke einen
kuchen von wahnsinn der ist allerdings
seit april abgelaufen nur an
selbstabholer ja da würde ich definitiv
vorbei fahren ich liebe abgelaufenen
kuchen und das hier ist das nächste
anzeige bild das nicht gesehen habe auf
ebay und ich dachte mir hey das ist ein
cooler fotoapparat und den kann man auch
kaufen also der preise als in cetera
stimmt auch allerdings hat er sich beim
wort fotoapparat
es ist in seinen augen keine
fotoapparate sondern ein fotoapparat
ich glaube ich muss nicht normal das
hier ist das bild vom nächsten ebay feld
und zwar ist es ein bett man fragt sich
jetzt eventuell hey verkauft er die
bettwäsche oder die matratze oder
vielleicht sogar das ganze bett er
verkauft eine komplette küche ohne
geräte schreibt dann allerdings bei
derart bettel hin dann allerdings wieder
schlafzimmer besteht aus bett aus
rattern mit zwei kommoden ca 180 meter
schrank vier türen jahr dicker warum
schreibst du in den titel du verkaufst
eine komplette küche und alles andere
ist einfach voll mit informationen zu
deinem scheiß betz hier verkauft jemand
einen 46 zoll großen samsung fernseher
und eine person schreibt ihm ich biete
15 euro mit vielen grüßen
guten abend der terminus festpreis
bedeutet dass ich nicht verhandler
schönen abend noch
ich komme aus rostock kann man da
trotzdem preislich noch was machen ja
egal ob in einer preislich
13 statt dann klar eigentlich kann man
nichts machen aber wenn du aus rostock
kommt kann man sich das sehe ich noch
mal drüber unterhalten beim nächsten
ebay fällen geht es um einen defekten
laptop der für 20 euro verkauft wird da
fragt man sich jetzt eventuell hey fehlt
da vielleicht eine taste oder ist der
kopfhörer eingang schrott da fehlt das
komplette display geil richtig dran
bauen wo das ein toaster oder oder sein
co
[Musik]
hier verkauft jemand einen veganen bh
der wenig getragen wurde und zum
verschenken ist und er denkt was ich
jetzt vielleicht hey veganer bh wie kann
ein bh überhaupt nicht vegan sein
das ist doch nicht um auf jeden fall
verkauft er diesen er verkauft einfach
einen salatkopf mbh und ich weiß nicht
warum ich lache weil das ist einfach nur
richtig richtig tier verkauft jemand
kein produkt auf ebay sondern schreibt
einfachheit und das hier liest schreibt
mich kurz an und im titel steht ich
suche edle also 11 falls du jetzt
innerhalb der letzten drei jahre nicht
gefunden wurde dann schreib ihm doch
hier mal an es kommt zu uns doch den
gefallen hier verkauft jemand new kids
für 18 euro und schreibt die
beschreibung handzahm und cool ihr wisst
bescheid
also da dachte ich mir schon so bei der
beschreibung her erst mal was sind new
kids vor allem für 18 euro das muss
irgendwie ein krasser nougat sein denn
so eine komische beschreibung von wegen
handzahm und cool ich meine das vorher
angeguckt er verkauft diese nougat biz
also kellogg's die in der milch schon
schwimmen
das ist definitiv menschen ist ziemlich
abstoßen beim nächsten event fälle
handelt es sich nicht um irgendein
komisches angebot oder um irgendwelche
rechtschreibfehler im angebot oder der
beschreibung oder um eine konversation
zwischen zwei leuten
es handelt sich einfach nur ein paar
nachrichten von der gleichen person uns
verschreibt er wie verschicken sie es
meine adresse ist pi geld ist bezahlt
wie wird das schon verschickt bezahlt
dann wird es verschickt wie und wann
wird es versteckt liebe grüss sondern
fragt sich hey warum antwortet der
verkäufer nicht wenn man dann allerdings
nur auf die zeiten guckt sieht man er
hat alle nachrichten in nicht mal einer
halben stunde verschickt sind dicker
vielleicht war er beim sport oder
einfach mal fett kacken so einfach dein
leben bei uns im luca shop ist es auch
häufig so dass wirklich leute bestellen
und zwei stunden später schreiben die
hay fand wann geht es denn jetzt raus so
hey ich weiß noch dass nachmittag
bestellt da sind wir vielleicht alle
gerade kuchen fressen und bundesliga
gucken aber vor luca schon früher habe
ich in jedem video nahezu meinen job
erwähnen wie es gerade mal aufgefallen
ich habe das irgendwie seit wochen nicht
gemacht ich trage die ganze zeit meine
merchandising beispielsweise dick und
doof von dem podcast versanden mir wohl
letzten tag auch eine neue folge online
kurz werbung was kann ich noch werbung
machen meine pizza als immer noch
draussen luca pizza drei dahinten das
ist
ich habe einmal ein buch herausgebracht
das könne bei amazon kaufen da erlernt
ihr ganz viel über mich so voll viel
kram rufen können ich noch werbung
machen höchsten einen spaß freuen ich
wollte euch nur ganz gut sagen wenn hier
noch nichts auf meinem shop hat oder
auch wenn ihr schon was hat schauen wir
mal wieder vom beitrag ja auch gerade
merchandise shop url
allerdings machen wir jetzt weiter mit
dem nächsten ebay fehl und zwar ist
dieser hier
da denkt man jetzt vielleicht haye der
verschenkt seine pizza und wohnt
irgendwie in berlin also ganz viele
leute sind und sich vielleicht einer
denkt hey ich hab hunger hat ich kaufe
die pizza ab nee eher verkauft einfach
den leeren karton für fünf euro hat ihn
eingestellt in der kategorie beauty und
gesundheit der beschreibung schreibt er
hallo verkaufen einen niegelnagelneuen
frisch versifften pizzakarton mit
inklusive unseres umzugs schweiz nur
selbstabholer für die adresse pm
willst du dir nicht einfach 30 auf den
kopf schlagen mit dem karton kommen
allerdings auch schon zu den drei
letzten liebenfels wenn die heutige
episode bei der lieben freunde uns war
es ist das hier das ist der drittletzte
bitte lesen hier aus dortmund
beschreibung ist ich bin auch mit 24
jahre alt ich wohne alleine und ich
möchte neue leute kennenlernen ich bin
ganz ehrlich es ist eigentlich ziemlich
süß geschrieben und wenn er wirklich
neue stadt gezogen ist in dem fall halt
neu nach dortmund dann finde ich echt
ganz schlimm kommt nun allerdings zum
vorletzten ebay für die heutige folge
zwar geht es um eine ikea schrank und zu
werfen ein interessent schreibt einfach
richtig trocken lasst mich den letzten
preis für deinen wie bitte also manche
leute auf ebay schecks wirklich nicht
und dass auch hier beim letzten die
befehle der fall eine person schreibt
mit einer anderen person namens samantha
und zwar schreibt die person hallo ich
möchte sie informieren dass ich das
fahrzeug anderweitig verkauft habe ihnen
einen guten rutsch
daraufhin antwortet verband hat vielen
dank für die info und besorgen denn die
sich etwas mehr rückgrat
lassmann daumen hoch beim video da wenn
ihr also auch findet dass die sich ein
bisschen mehr rückgrat fand deshalb wird
jetzt auch beenden meiner lieben freude
wenn ihr noch keins hat der user
abonniert auf jeden fall gerne einen
kanal unter dem video ist kostenlos und
verpasst keine videos mehr anwender
klickt kann auf die glocke dann bekommt
ihr direkt eine benachrichtigung wenn
ich täglich ein neues video hochladen
aber jetzt würde ich sagen steck ich
mein kopf in mülleimer und hoffe dass
ich da wieder rausfinden werde
[Musik]